- [Interviewer] All right, Lee.
Lee, where'd you grow up?
Where you from originally?
- [Lee] Originally from Dayton, Tennessee,
right between Nashville and Chattanooga.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your family.
You had both of your
parents when you were young?
- Yeah, I lost my mom when I was nine.
I lost my dad when I was 17.
- [Interviewer] And how would
you describe your childhood?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] How would
you describe your childhood?
- We didn't have much.
We were a poor family.
I wouldn't say completely poor,
but mostly-
- [Interviewer] That whole
region is fairly poor.
- Yeah, mostly blackland
farmer is what they call 'em.
- [Interviewer] What
is a blackland farmer?
- Where they do farm work off and on,
here and there for people.
- [Interviewer] And any abuse?
Any kind of craziness in your childhood?
- None.
- Nothing?
- Uh huh.
- [Interviewer] And how
far did you go in school?
- I lacked three weeks to
finish the seventh grade.
- [Interviewer] And
that's as far as you went?
- Yeah, 'cause they was
passing me on D's and F's.
I never didn't do that
good in school anyhow.
I failed the first grade,
and I failed the sixth,
and I quit in the seventh.
- [Interviewer] What'd you do after that?
- What'd I do after that?
Well, I went and registered for the Army,
but they turned me down
'cause they classified me as A,
but then never went for my exam,
they classified me as 4-F.
And so, after that,
I just, whatever kind
of work I could pick up,
that's what I done.
In other words, I'm a Jack of all trades
and a master of none.
- [Interviewer] And then,
do you have any kids?
Ever married?
- Yes, I've been married twice.
I've got three kids.
Two kids by the first wife,
I got one kid out of wedlock that's mine.
And then I had, my second marriage,
I had four stepdaughters.
- [Interviewer] And then at
some point you got in trouble
with the law?
- Yeah, in 1984.
You see, me and the old
lady would have been married
for about, me and my first wife,
been married about 14, 15 years.
Let's see, my first child
with her was born in April of
'74.
And my son was born in '76.
And after my son was born,
me and the wife,
we didn't have sex or nothing.
She cut me off completely.
I used to drink a lot.
I put that all down in '67.
Oh wait, '97 really.
I put it all down, quit it all
September the 21st of '97.
And
my wife, she decided one day,
she wanted a divorce.
I told her, I said,
"Well, whenever I married you,
I didn't marry you to give you no divorce.
"Well, I'll get it one way or the other!"
And so that's when I was accused
of messing with my daughter and my niece.
And that's whenever I started
getting in trouble with the law then.
DUIs, I had a few of them.
Because I used to drink
a lot back, years ago.
And just like I said,
I put it all down in '97
and ain't touched it sense.
- [Interviewer] Right.
And the incidents with the kids,
that was something that
actually happened or?
- No, she accused me of it
'cause she wanted a divorce.
That's how she got her divorce.
- [Interviewer] So, you
claim it never happened?
- Nope, it never happened.
I mean, somebody did
mess with my daughter.
The fella that did mess with her,
he died while I was locked up.
- [Interviewer] How many
years in prison did you do?
- I done 15 years in prison.
19 years at Arcadia,
at what you you call it?
- [Interviewer] Was that therapy?
- Yeah, therapy.
19 years in there.
- [Interviewer] So a total of-
- 37.
37, 38 that I've been locked up. (coughs)
- [Interviewer] And looking
back at all of that,
how do you view all that?
Do you feel like you just got robbed or?
- Well no, I feel that I got
cheated out of a marriage,
out of my kids.
I ain't seen them since '84.
- [Interviewer] I mean 37
years in prison is rough.
- Yeah, it is.
It sure is.
- [Interviewer] And
for something you claim
you are innocent of that makes it tough.
- But just like I said,
the fellow that did mess with her,
and if she would've said something to me,
I'd have took care of it
'cause that's the way I do.
I take care of my family, you know?
But then, after I got locked up,
he ended up dying.
So, I didn't have nothing
to do with that. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] Right.
And what emotions does
this all bring up for you?
Do you struggle with like
depression or anger or anxiety?
- [Lee] A little bit of both.
Depression, anger on account of,
like I said, I ain't seen
my kids since '84, so.
- [Interviewer] And how
is your relationship
with your daughter,
or with the rest of your family?
- [Lee] Well, my daughter and my son,
we got along good.
I mean, like a father and kids should.
My rest of my family,
we were close knit,
my sisters and brothers
until I got in trouble.
And then when I went to prison,
they all just seem to bury off.
I still talk to my baby
sister though once in a while.
I call her up and talk to her.
So, she's the only one that I talk to.
- [Interviewer] And your,
is it a daughter and a
stepdaughter that you?
- [Lee] It's my daughter and my niece.
- [Interviewer] And your niece.
Do you have any contact with them?
- [Lee] No.
- [Interviewer] Not at all?
- [Lee] None at all.
- [Interviewer] Since that incident,
have you spoken?
- Nope.
- Never?
- [Lee] 'Cause like I said,
I hadn't seen 'em since '84.
That's when I got locked.
- [Interviewer] I mean,
if your niece and daughter
knew you were not the not the predator,
you'd think they would have
reached out to you at some point.
- No, they done what their mama said.
'Cause, just like I said,
they were 10 year old.
My daughter was.
And my niece was nine.
So, they got together,
my wife, my sister-in-law
and my other sister-in-law,
and they come up with
that to get a divorce.
- [Interviewer] Did they say
in court that you were guilty?
- Well, I took a no contest,
no contest plea 'cause I told my lawyer,
I said, "I don't want to put
my kids through any trouble.
I know how these here courts do 'em,
and they cross examine and all this.
And I said, "They're too young for that."
So I went ahead and took a
plea bargain just like I said.
I've done 15 years in prisons,
and 19 up there at Arcadia
in that there sexual rehabilitating,
- [Interviewer] Yeah, and
how'd you take to the therapy?
- Eh.
I made it through it, you know?
- [Interviewer] What kind
of things did they work on?
- Well, they work on your attitudes,
your sexual thoughts
and things like that.
- [Interviewer] And yet you
had another marriage after this, right?
- Yes.
- When you got out of prison?
- Well, not when I got out of prison.
Well, I got out,
and then I had to go back
on a violation of probation.
But, let's see,
my second marriage,
we got married in '80,
let's see '84?
No, '80, '90?
About '90, '91.
Then we got a divorce in '92,
and never went back on the
violation of probation.
- [Interviewer] What lesson
has this all taught you?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] What have
you learned from all of this?
- I learned to be careful
who I mess with. (laughing)
Very careful.
- [Interviewer] What are you doing now?
Are you staying away from kids?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] And do you
have any friends today?
- Oh yeah.
I've got a girlfriend now.
I was just with her a
while before you come.
- [Interviewer] And
looking back at your life,
do you have any regrets?
- Looking back at it?
Yes, I have regrets 'cause I regret
that I was accused of something
that I didn't do, you know?
- [Interviewer] What would
you have done differently
if you could?
- Well, if I could go back
and do things over,
I don't think I'd ever
gotten married. (laughs)
Just on account of the way
the first wife treated me.
So.
'Cause I was a virgin there.
Me and her got married,
and just like I said,
after my son was born in '76,
we didn't have sex,
but we was together for about 15 year.
14, 15 year.
- [Interviewer] All right Lee.
Well, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- You're welcome.
- [Interviewer] And I wish
you and your girlfriend
the best of luck.
- Well, this here gal,
lady that I'm going with,
I think she's just a few
years younger than me.
She was born in '52 I think, or '53.
So, we seem to be hitting
it off pretty good.
- [Interviewer] Good luck with that.
- Oh yeah.
- [Interviewer] All right.
Thank you Lee.
- Oh yes.
- Okay.
- Thank you.